Rocket main Moon and bottle.
Boop. You smell that.
I could smell that under water.
Well don't look at me.
Let's get out of here. Agreed.
The smells of the universe are not universal.
Listen. You smell something
Different. Objects in space like
comets planets moons gas clouds.
Each have their own distinctive aroma.
I love this melody universe in the morning.
Me too. We're all watching the expanse right.
If you're not. Start immediately it's the best sci
fi show on TV and it's based on a
series of novels which are equally awesome.
And I will link below. Anyway the expanse
describes the moon as having a gunpowder stink
and I remember reading that and
thinking what a cool description.
And it made me wonder how
did they come up with that.
Does the moon really smell like gunpowder.
Turns out it does. For this video we're going
it was still no moon landing was not faked.
We are going to assume
the moon landing was real.
You'll believe anything.
When recalling the smell of the moon Apollo
17 Jack Schmidt said everyone's impression of
the smell was that of spent gunpowder.
And this is strange because the makeup
of lunar dust is completely different than
gunpowder Moon Regolith is made up of silicon
dioxide glass created by billions of years
of media impacts. It also
contains iron calcium and magnesium.
But modern gunpowder is a combination
of nitro cellulose and nitroglycerin.
So why the similarity.
Well nobody really knows but it could be
a sign that moon dust is chemically active.
So how does the smell even happen.
Well there are a couple of theories.
One is called a desert rain effect.
You ever notice that awesome smell that happens
after a summer rain that smells called
Petra core from the Greek words
Petra meaning rock or stone.
And the word. Which is the fluid that flows
through the veins of the gods on earth.
Plant oils accumulate on rocks during dry
periods along with another compound yachtsman
which is a metabolic byproduct of bacteria found
in soil and during rain the oils and
Joe's men are released into the air
causing that distinctive smell of petrol corn.
And if there's lightning sometimes you
could sniff a little ozone.
Obviously there are no plants on the
moon but there's still stuff right.
The molecules trapped in the dry moon dust
may have been activated by contact with the
moist air in the lunar module just like
Patrick wore in the desert rain effect.
Another theory is solar winds hot Solar Winds
of hydrogen helium and other ions Buffett
the moon's surface and may become trapped in the
dust when the ions are dislodged such as
by an astronaut's footsteps then come in contact
with the warm air inside the lunar
module they evaporate.
That's possible these ions were brought
into the cabin producing the odor.
Either way the smell didn't last long.
By the time the moon dust made it
back to Earth it was completely odorless.
So we'll have to take NASA's word for it
but space itself may even have a smell.
Astronauts returning from spacewalks have reported smelling
burnt metal or burnt meat and
no one really knows for sure what this is
but it could be molecules of metal leeching off
onto spacesuits then oxidizing when it comes
into contact with actual humidifier air.
Now I think that's super interesting.
So let's work our way around the solar
system and see which planet smells like toasted
almonds and which planet smells like the porta
potty on the last day of Renaissance fair.
That reference was oddly specific
Mercury. Mercury is the smallest and closest planet
to the sun named after the Greek god
Hermes and translated into
Latin is more curious.
The messenger of the gods and Mercury contains a
lot of sodium which doesn't have much of
an odor but there's also a lot
of silicon dioxide present like the moon.
So we assume the smell would
be gunpowder just salty gunpowder.
Venus Venus is the second planet from the sun
named after the Roman goddess of love and
beauty. When they name the planet
they clearly couldn't smell it.
Venus has a thick
atmosphere mostly carbon dioxide.
There's also a heavy clouds of sulfuric acid.
That combination makes Venus smell like
a burnt match and rotten eggs.
Mars is the fourth planet from the sun and
the second smallest planet in the solar system
being larger than only Mercury named
for the Roman god of war.
Mars is often referred to as the red planet
because of the iron oxide on the surface.
And despite what Matt Damon would tell you
Mars doesn't have much of an atmosphere since
Mars lost its magnetic sphere
billions of years ago.
Solar Winds are constantly stripping away
atoms from the outer layer.
But what atmosphere there is contains
methane formaldehyde carbon monoxide and sulfur
dioxide. The Martian sand smells like rusty
metal because that's when iron oxide is
combining the owners of the surface with the orders
of the air and Mars is probably going
to smell like the exhaust of an
old car with a bad catalytic converter.
It's basically the same stuff.
And yeah you can't breathe that.
I'm definitely going to die out there.
Jupiter. Jupiter is the fifth planet from the
sun and the largest in the solar system.
It's a gas giant named after
the king of the Roman gods.
Jupiter's atmosphere is five thousand kilometres
thick and actually has multiple layers
each with slightly different smells.
The outer layers have a lot of
ammonia which smells like horse urine.
As you move closer to the surface
the atmosphere becomes more sulfuric smelling like
skunk And horse urine.
The inner layers have a high concentration
of hydrogen cyanide which smells like toasted
almonds and skunk and horse
urine and rotten eggs.
Saturn is the six planet from the sun
and the second largest in the solar system.
After Jupiter it's also a gas giant named
after the Roman god of wealth and agriculture.
Saturn's atmosphere is 96 percent hydrogen and 4
percent helium so not much of a smell
but there are trace amounts of methane
phosphate in acetylene and ammonia and fostering
can smell like rotten fish like So Saturn
probably smells like dead fish and skunk and
rotten eggs.
What's your eggs.
Good question. Eggs are very
high in two proteins.
Globulin and keratin.
When globulin decays a toxic chemicals released
hydrogen sulfide which has a very potent
sulfur smell. I mean.
You know it when you smell it and keratin
also has very high levels of an amino acid
called system which is also full of sulfur hydrogen
sulfide happens to be one of the most
common compounds in the solar system.
So. Rotten eggs everywhere
Uranus. Uranus.
Here. Yes please.
Please don't say it that way.
You say tomato I say you read this
to me all you read is potato.
Do you mind. Go ahead.
I couldn't resist.
Uranus is the seventh planet from the
sun named for the Greek god.
That's Greek god of the sky.
That's probably the smelliest planet
in the solar system.
Stop it. The upper atmosphere is mostly
hydrogen so not much of a smell.
But as you get closer to
the surface it gets pretty ripe.
Heavily drilled Uranus.
Yes. We have no hope.
Go with gentle. So why
does Uranus smell so bad.
Well the cloud tops of Uranus are made
of hydrogen sulfide that gas responsible for the
foul smell of rotten eggs and.
Human flatulence e
A little lower in the atmosphere you'll find methane
and ammonia so So you mean it smells
like a public toilet. It does
Need to named after the Roman god of the sea.
Neptune is the 8th and far this planet from the
sun at 17 times the mass of the earth.
It's slightly more massive than its twin Uranus
as it smell as bad as Uranus.
Well most of the compounds are frozen in
the atmosphere so really just hydrogen and
helium are present. Neptune doesn't have
much of a smell at all.
That's too bad. I got my jokes.
No I'm sure you do everywhere else.
A few honourable mentions dwarf planet Pluto is
a near vacuum with nitrogen methane and
carbon monoxide so deadly but odorless one of
Saturn's moons and syllabus is covered in
ice but underneath it has an
ocean of liquid salt water.
It was recently discovered that plumes of methanol
are ejected from the surface so it
could smell like a martini.
I'm Steve o. This is the Poo Cocktail
supreme comments mostly smell like burnt metal and
of course rotten eggs and lots of
asteroids contain formaldehyde and cyanide so they
could smell like pickles and marzipan.
No sounds like what my ex-wife
thought when she was pregnant.
You've been married three times.
Huh. I didn't know that.
Well I had a life before
you came along you know.
OK OK take it easy.
Sorry sorry I am still
working through some things.
Anyway the center of our galaxy is the
dust cloud Sagittarius B2 and in that cloud
scientists have discovered a substance called ethyl
for me which is the chemical
responsible for the flavor of raspberries
and the smell of rum.
So Not so bad.
So here's what we learned today was that the
worst smelling thing in a solar system is
Uranus. I hate you
Thanks for hanging out with us today.
My name is AJ. That's Hegel fish.
This has been why files have you
had fun or learned anything today.
Do us a favor give us a thumbs up.
It really helps up the channel.
Oh and whoever makes the best Uranus joke
in the comments wins an amazon gift card.
Oh I get why you're
disqualified now until next time.
Be safe Be kind and
know that you are appreciated.
You know I heard there's a
black hole near your anus.
You stop it.